aí vai começar vai começar o ted música
olha essa bola vermelha que essa
investida bola vermelha que os íntimos e
tias energia que a fumar mas não deu
você você você pode sair
ai ai olha eu perdendo tempo brincando
essa foi uma das frases que eu mais
escuto na minha vida perdendo tempo
brincando quando era criança e quentinho
eu gostava de me divertir brincar criar
jogos e entreter os meus amigos vou
mostrar pra vocês que olha mágica nem é
uma coxa
isso era perder tempo para os meus
mestres eles falavam pra mim se você
continuar perdendo tempo você vai ser um
perdedor
aquela palavra não fazia muito sentido
para mim ser um perdedor se eu não
estava jogando o jogo nenhum
mas eles eram meus mestres né
eu tinha que seguir o que ele estava
falando e eu resolvi aplicar o que eles
falavam no tênis eu ia ser um campeão de
tse repetir milhões e milhões diversas a
mesma batida
até me tornar um campeão mas de vez em
quando eu tinha umas recaídas
olha olha essa aqui ó vocês vão ficar de
cara de cá e não é com um show a coisa
tá ali ó nem e olha que o medo de uma
outra que a gente fazia quando a gente
era criança quer uma seqüência que ó
solta o som lá pra mim ó
sabe lá o que é bom
a poeta pirueta todo mundo pode falar
[Música]
espontâneo vocês não têm mais e vai ser
mas olha só que legal estou gostando
cada quilo
[Música]
só eu sei que também canta
a bola que é mais uma mas uma mais uma
mas outra mas o
[Música]
aí peguei soró valor
crio era mais uma vez mais uma mais um
[Música]
calma calma calma eu sei o que estou
fazendo
calma calma não é só mais uma
[Música]
ai meu deus a bola aqui ó
ela só para você participar um arco
agora na última chance
aí peguei peguei a bola e criou lugar
sete bolas
ae nem eu acreditava que acertar mentira
eu treinei bastante a dança pode parar a
música para dar uma respirada
eu vou fazer uma mágica pra vocês a
mágica é incrível não
pois é os meus mestres e será perda de
tempo
e foi numa dessas recaídas de perda de
tempo que eu tive uma experiência que
mudou a minha vida era uma final de
campeonato de tênis arquibancada lotada
metade da torcida a seu favor
metade da torcida a favor do adversário
é um ponto decisivo eu estava próximo à
rede como o adversário jogou a bola por
cima de mim ea conclusão era simples
bater de cima para baixo
uma tal porta assim como os meus mestres
falava sem perder tempo mas tinha a
segunda opção perder tempo brincando eu
deixei essa bola passar por cima de mim
correr de costas para a rede sem ter a
visão do adversário do tipo de baixo das
pernas
só bola passou por cima da rede entrou
na quadra eu tinha feito pontos
olhei para minha torcida a torcida
aplaude no olímpico a torcida adversário
ele começará pôde olhei para o meu
adversário ele soltou a raquete abriu um
sorriso e começou a pode aquele momento
foi o único especial
todo mundo se divertindo o jogo
continuou e eu perdi
é ninguém é perfeito
sabe de uma coisa naquele momento eu me
conectei com todas aquelas pessoas e eu
sentir que a gente estava vencendo um
campeonato de tênis tem vários escritos
e quem ganha é uma pessoa essa pessoa
fica feliz o resto
perdi a ai ai
foi ali que eu vi a oportunidade de
criar um novo jogo e nesse novo jogo não
existiria a competição não existiria
perdedor
a ideia era fazer mais pessoas
vivenciarem aquela energia que a gente
tinha vivenciado no tênis e foi aí que
eu fui atrás de técnicas que mudassem o
estado de humor das pessoas e eu vi que
os artistas faziam isso muito bem
foi aí que eu me inspirei em que eu
comecei os meus treinos e as minhas
pesquisas pode soltar o som
[Música]
obrigada eu aprendi mágica malabarismo
saxofone bateria e construir
instrumentos diferentes e uma técnica
tinha certeza que ia fazer as pessoas se
divertirem era fazer malabarismo com 7
argolas na minha cabeça era certo se eu
terminasse uma apresentação com 7
argolas as pessoas ficariam muito feliz
mas eu também sabia que eu ia ter que
treinar muito para conseguir
foram 12 anos até conseguir
e quando conseguiu colocar no palco e
adivinha o que aconteceu
eu errei na época eu não levei na
brincadeira foi bem frustrante eu juntei
tudo
joguei de novo eu errei de novo quanto
mais eu errava mais desesperado ficava
aquela frustração e é pra mim ea platéia
e eu sentia que estava perdendo o jogo
que tinha construído
tava todo mundo perdendo junto foram
várias apresentações até entender que eu
não estava mais feliz não estava mais me
divertindo não estava mais sendo quem eu
era
eu estava jogando o jogo que tinha um
ensinado quando era criança eu tinha que
ser perfeito eu tinha que treinar oito
horas por dia e mais importante eu não
podia errar e só assim eu ia poder fazer
as pessoas felizes como é difícil a
gente aceitar o erro né entendeu erro e
entender que errar nos torna inferiores
mas uma coisa é a arte me ensinou que as
pessoas elas se conectam através das
falhas humanas
elas identificam com erro quando você
faz coisas incríveis você se distancia
das pessoas quando você erra as pessoas
elas se sentem próximas de você se torna
um parte de um grupo e foi entendendo
isso que eu comecei a ver o erro como
uma coisa boa quando eu ia acontecer uma
maneira de me conectar ainda mais com a
platéia uma maneira de evoluir criar
coisas novas e aí os momentos de
frustração passaram a ser momentos de
diversão como esse aqui ó
[Aplausos]
é isso me fez entender que as pessoas
ficavam felizes quando eu estava feliz
em diferente do erro e eu estava feliz
quando estava me divertindo brincando e
não quando eu tinha que ser perfeito
então a idéia era brincar mais me
divertir mais errar mais
foi aí que eu criei um número onde eu
entrava com figurino todo desalinhado
uma gravata pendurada no meu bolso ea
primeira coisa que eu fazia quando eu
olhava a platéia era deixar tudo cair no
chão
aceitando as minhas falhas mostrando os
meus erros e deixando aparecer novos
erros deixando a minha espontaneidade
brincar com isso e me divertindo
o resultado desse número foi esse aqui ó
[Aplausos]
na criação desse número aceitei quem eu
era
mostrei as minhas falhas e não perdi a
minha essência e para minha surpresa eu
tinha sido selecionado para o festival
internacional de circo um dos maiores
festivais de circo do mundo
lá eu pude compartilhar minha felicidade
com os meus ídolos
estava lá o filho do chefe shopping o
diretor do moulin rouge
a diretora do circo da china e o de
diretor sênior do casting do cirque du
solei além disso eu pude compartilhar o
palco com artistas que eu nunca imaginei
que ele está perto
foi uma experiência única nessa
caminhada em busca dos meus sonhos eu vi
várias experiências
conheci pessoas incríveis tive a
oportunidade de participar dos maiores
programas de televisão do brasil teve
dois vídeos visualizados que me levaram
a fazer campanhas internacionais e o
mais genial de compartilhar momentos de
felicidade com muita gente como esses
aqui ó
o que parecia ser perda de tempo para
muita gente pra mim fazia continua
fazendo muito sentido e sabe que é mais
genial é que talvez as experiências que
eu vivi não faça um sentido para alguma
pessoa realmente pareciam ser perda de
tempo e isso é lindo porque se você
corre atrás dos seus sonhos
você se torna livre para usufruir das
experiências suas
hoje eu entendo que perda de tempo
depende de ponto de vista
e aí eu termino uma pergunta pra vocês
que é quanto às experiências vocês
deixaram de viver e quantos sonhos vocês
deixaram de realizar por acreditar que
era perda de tempo
[Aplausos]